affrontement gauche-droite au Conseil
régional d'Île-de-France sur le SDRIF le
document qui dessine le visage de la
région d'ici à 2030 pour l'UMP cedrift
n'est pas acceptable il repose sur le
projet du métro automatique du Grand
Paris un dossier pour lequel l'État n'a
pas mis le milliard manquant sur la
table moi je dis attention danger ce
schéma directeur qui permet au maire
d'urbaniser et de créer de l'emploi
partout en Île-de-France c'est des
embouteillages c'est des RER saturés
c'est des lignes de train qui ne
tiendront pas le choc pour l'UMP la
noninscription du milliard d'euros par
l'État pour le Grand Paris pose la
question de la légitimité de ce nouveau
SRIF une motion de rejet a été déposée
par Valérie PCR du côté de la majorité
de gauche on maintient le cap il est
nécessaire de renouveler lerif dès
maintenant l'enjeu c'est de sortir d'un
schéma directeur qui date de 94 donc
vous imaginez un petit peu l'obsolesence
de ce document et c'est de faire en
sorte de répondre à des défis qui sont
défis très très concrets come on se loge
comment on se nourrit comment on
travaille le SDRIF a suscité le dépôt de
plus de 300 amendements la gauche
disposant de la majorité lerift devrait
être voté sans difficulté toutefois son
adoption et son approbation ne devrait
pas intervenir avant la fin de l'année
2013 à l'issue d'une enquête publique
qui doit débuter en mars